oh it's okay you're fine the way that
you are no it's not okay the only people
that are accepted however they come are
women not men you must become a somebody
as a man I think that's why our podcast
become so popular because we're telling
guys there is a burden of performance
you have to go out there and do
something being fat is unacceptable
being stupid is unacceptable beating me
okay mediocre is unacceptable you can't
be saved like a woman can for being
pretty you must get out there and become
a somebody but the problem is that we
don't bully you guys enough we don't
tell them that they're losers we don't
tell them that they're fat we don't tell
them that they're stupid we need to go
back to letting people know that they're
inadequate and then they'll go ahead and
you know it's wild that he's saying that
somebody could be listening to this and
saying what kind of a freaking message
is that I grew up bullying and this this
that